handcuffed and escorted by U.S Marshals
former president Alejandro Toledo landed
in Peru early Sunday after losing a
final bid to prevent his extradition
a few supporters waited outside the
airport
we came to support our leader because he
was the best president he left the
economy stable we used to have 10 pieces
of bread for a few cents and now we
can't afford anything
after a health checkup the 77 year old
former leader met Peru's top prosecutor
Patricia Benavides her team has been
pursuing Toledo's extradition to face
charges since 2017.
then his first appearance in court
I am in economics and International
Education professor at Stanford
University currently retired Toledo was
read his rights and charges pollution
and money laundering he faces up to 20
years in prison control the accusation
his brother Pedro Toledo says public
opinion has already condemned him
officials are giving statements as if he
was already sentenced a government
Minister has described president Toledo
as a criminal that is a prejudgment
Witnesses have told prosecutors Toledo
received 35 million dollars in bribes in
exchange for Public Works contracts
charges he has denied Toledo says he
will die if he goes to prison he wants
Peru's Judiciary to allow him to remain
under house arrest but prosecutors here
say it's been a fugitive since 2017 and
they believed he will try to escape
Alejandro Toledo now joins five former
presidents under investigation for
corruption for now from a prison cell
Adriana sanchezida Lima
lost muscle to come here in Al Jazeera
including